efectivamente creo que el entorno de
estas nuevas reuniones
es propicio para hacer varios análisis
uno de ellos es lo que usted menciona yo
creo que la confianza estaba
resquebrajada la confianza desde que
surgió la pandemia por ejemplo entre los
países ha desatado una guerra
geopolítica particularmente sobre el
tema de la vacuna y evidentemente en el
acuerdo entre de australia eeuu y reino
unido sobre el tema de los submarinos en
ese sentido creo que sí fue un grave
error del presi de eeuu el debilitar esa
relación esa fortaleza que tiene con
francia y si evidentemente la confianza
se tiene que demostrar con hechos y no
con palabras y eso creo que es una frase
que se le dedica presente eeuu de que
debe de pasar cierto tiempo para limar
esas asperezas y de alguna manera creo
que si fueron lamentables porque porque
eeuu y la unión europea particularmente
francia pues son socios aliados son
importantes socios que de alguna manera
tienen que estar juntos para competir
con nuevas amenazas señor pretelín ahora
cómo interpretar la ausencia de dos
líderes de gran peso como lo son el ruso
vladimir putin y el chino xi jinping
sí efectivamente creo que el tema
insisto geopolítico creo que está la
gana le está ganando la agenda al g20 y
obviamente a la cob 26 el tema de otra
vez eeuu que dice el presidente de
bailén que cuente con su apoyo a taiwán
en desde punto de vista de los del
armamento lo dijo públicamente creo que
eso cayó muy feo y muy fuerte allá en
china y sin embargo creo que hay
elementos importantes que hay que
conseguir poner en consideración hay que
recordar que el ministro de defensa de
taiwán fue al parlamento hace un par de
semanas y dijo que el 2025 podría
recibir un acto bélico de parte de china
en taiwán lo cual eso hace muy peligroso
el tema de rusia también es importante
hay que ver que ésta haya acabado este
oleoducto este gasoducto que de alguna
manera pacto con alemania y que tampoco
gustó mucho a eeuu aún cuando ya de
alguna manera está negociado las
ausencias de putin también las ausencias
del primer ministro de japón porque hay
elecciones este fin de semana la
ausencia del presidente de méxico porque
nos interesa la parte internacional creo
que habla de evidentemente que las
circunstancias todavía no están
corriendo con cierta normalidad pero sí
hay que celebrar ella
ya se van a reunir físicamente los
líderes y creo que es muy importante
hablar ya de la cob 26 pero señor
pretende muy brevemente que podemos
esperar de este g-20 habrá avances por
ejemplo en términos de repartición más
equitativa de las vacunas para poner fin
a la pandemia
creo que este es un elemento importante
lado ms dijo que en realidad en todas
las pruebas como el número de vacunas
aplicadas en países pobres es
ridículamente muy bajo lo cual creo que
este g-20 tiene que de alguna manera
apoyar esta agenda de que ahora sí se
debe de canalizar muchas vacunas y
muchas pruebas anti kobe a los países
más desfavorecidos creo que ese es uno
de los de las ausencias de las faltas de
atención que ha tenido los grandes
países industrializados durante los
últimos 12 meses creo que sí se han
abocado a vacunar a sus respectivos
ciudadanos pero se han olvidado los
demás hay que decir que eeuu se ha
donado al menos en el caso de méxico más
de 10 millones de dosis y a otras partes
del mundo pero si falta mucho